[Music]
there's a small volcanic island off the
southern coast of Japan called magashima
nobody lives here
but here's footage from January 2023 of
construction workers arriving to this
island their task is to build a couple
of runways on the island and some
storage facilities for ammunition the
Japanese government has been paying
local fishermen to stay away from this
island that's because they're turning it
into a military base
the island is being built by Japan but
one of its main purposes has to do with
the United States American fighter jets
and aircraft carriers have had to do
their drills and practices down here on
this island but now they're able to
station at this island moving them much
closer to this ocean and to one country
in particular
magashima is just one of many islands
that are being loaded up with military
hardware most of it coming from the
United States it's part of this chain of
militarized islands an effort of defense
or aggression depending on how you look
at it it's a line that centers on Taiwan
and it's what one official was referring
to when they said that 2023 is likely to
stand as the most transformative year in
U.S force posture in this region in a
generation this line is a symbol of the
rising tensions between Global
superpowers and I want to show you why
this is happening now and what it means
for the future of this conflict this is
unlike anything the U.S Navy has done
since World War II pensions are rising
in one of the most hotly contested
regions on the planet the South China
Sea
immediately
[Music]
hey I'm gonna pause the story really
quick to tell you about uh today's
sponsor who's co-pilot which is a
product that I actually use almost every
day of my life copilot is a platform
where you get paired up with a fitness
coach you meet with that Fitness coach
it's a real person it's not like an AI
and that Fitness coach talks to you
about your fitness goals and then they
design a custom fitness plan for you
using their app every day when I do my
workout I just open up the app and I hit
start workout and it guides me through
with video demonstrations and a timer
through every one of my exercises these
are exercises that are literally
designed for me and my goals and my
goals aren't to like get buff I'm just
trying to like work out so that I feel
strong and feel good in my body and that
is what my workout is designed to do it
also pairs up with my watch so that it
cues me onto the next exercise
oftentimes I'm like listening to a
podcast or a book or music and I can
just visually see all of these cues it's
incredibly convenient and very smooth at
the end of my workout I had the
opportunity to then communicate with my
coach and say like hey I wanted a little
bit more like Core workout or like the
push-ups were too intense this time
let's tone it down and then my coach
Devin will actually modify my workout
for the next day so that it fits my
feedback what I love about copilot is
that it's much more about accountability
like when I work out I know that there's
somebody who's going to check in with me
and ask how the workout went co-pilot
found that their clients are nine times
more likely to stick to their goals when
they have a real person coach who is
designing a workout for them which is
like not surprising to me of course they
are accountability and consistency is
the hardest thing with Fitness as we all
know and copilot solves that by pairing
you up with a real person I've been
doing this now for like eight months and
it's been really really cool I've
changed my workout a bunch I've like met
with my coach and like reshaped my
entire workout based on new goals and I
just think it's a fantastic platform so
thank thank you co-pilot for sponsoring
the video there's a link in my
description it is
go.myco-pilot.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gives you 14 days of free
copilot access to your own personal
fitness coach you can test it out and
see if it helps you with accountability
and fitness which is something we all
need to feel good in our bodies so thank
you copilot for sponsoring today's video
Let's dive back into this important
story
here we go
okay so this document from the U.S
Department of Defense this document is
called the national defense strategy of
the United States of America which also
includes the nuclear posture review and
missile defense review it's basically a
report that they release every four
years that gives us an understanding of
what the US military is up to what they
care about
but this year's is more detailed than
normal the document focuses a lot on
China if China threatens our sovereignty
concerns directly with China the dod
says that China quote remains our most
consequential strategic competitor for
coming decades why because the Pentagon
says China is bullying its neighbors to
quote reshape the region and the
International System to fit its
authoritarian preferences now remember
that the United States who spends loads
on its military has set the rules for
our Global Order how we trade what
political systems we favor who
participates in the system and now we
see a country that wants to Dethrone
them to create a new system based on
other values and other rules
and what scares the US military is that
China is rapidly modernizing and
expanding their military China's middle
military is growing incredibly fast like
they deploy the equivalent of an entire
new British Navy every four years every
four years like new new British Navy
like new Royal Navy every four years
yeah they're just growing very quickly
this report is concerned about China's
growing strength and Military footprint
[Music]
how China is coercing its neighbors
disregarding ocean boundaries testing
missiles bullying fishing vessels in
other countries Waters building islands
and military bases on those islands and
flying over other countries airspace and
especially in Taiwan the island that
China claims as their own and where the
globe gets nearly all of their Advanced
microchips which is a topic I made an
entire video about the point is Taiwan
is an incredibly important Island for
the United States all of this together
makes China quote the only country that
has the intent and power to actually
challenge the us-led global order and
rewrite Global rules and Norms something
the U.S has gotten really comfortable
doing over the last 70 years so this is
why the U.S considers China the most
consequential strategic competitor for
coming decades and they've created a
plan to respond and in their words we
cannot delay they give themselves this
10-year window to implement some major
changes and this is what it looks like
okay first things first the US military
is already very very present in Asia
we've got about 8 000 troops in Guam
we've got over 100 bases in Japan with
about 21
000 American troops on the mainland and
another 24 000 station down here on the
Japanese island of Okinawa go up to
South Korea and you'll find 22 000 U.S
troops and then you've got the U.S Navy
who operates out of this port in
Singapore this has been the status quo
in Asia for decades and it has been the
way that the US has ensured security for
its allies and it's kind of mostly
worked to help secure American interests
and deter conflict the US has maintained
strong alliances in this region and
frankly the Pentagon has kind of been
distracted with other things two Wars
that happened in the Middle East over
the past 20 years my fellow citizens my
fellow citizens but as those conflicts
wind down and as China militarizes the
Department of Defense says that this
status quo all of these troops in Asia
it's not enough they talk about this new
kind of deterrent integrated deterrence
the only kind of military posture that
will actually keep China at Bay and this
is what it looks like the smallest part
of the strategy has to do with American
bases they're going to reopen a base in
Guam and move some troops there but the
majority of this strategy has to do with
American Allies in Asia allies that are
in lockstep with the US's goal to deter
and contain China depending on calls
partnering with its allies the center of
gravity for this strategy so let's start
with Japan one of the US's closest
allies in the region Japan is a country
that is deeply concerned about a more
powerful China with its massive Navy and
its Ambitions to control Taiwan and it's
very easy to forget that Japan isn't
just this it's actually all of this it
extends way down here because of all
these islands these islands curve nicely
all the way down until they hit Taiwan
all of these are Japanese Islands I mean
if you look at Japan's national defense
strategy translated into English you
will see something it looks strikingly
similar to what the Pentagon released
they're both really freaked out about
China and they both are ready to act in
lockstep to deter a more aggressive
China in the region so it starts up here
with that island that we talked about at
the beginning magashima this new
military base and airstrip to be used by
both Japanese and U.S militaries further
south is amami Island where Japan has
recently added long-range missiles and
anti-ship missiles potentially they're
going to add cruise missiles these are
missiles that they're buying from the
United States these are missiles that
are definitely in range of the Taiwan
Strait next to the chain is Okinawa
where the US has a huge presence of tens
of thousands of troops already Japan
also has military bases here and is
adding even more long-range missiles and
electronic warfare units for military
installations meant to disrupt and deny
communication signals on these two
islands down here they're adding even
more long-range missiles which could
potentially be used to attack Chinese
naval ships aircraft and Japan is
placing nearly 600 troops on ishigaki as
well and finally you've got this last
militarized island in the chain yonaguni
it's the closest island to Taiwan and
here Japan is adding more of those
electronic warfare units which are used
to jam communication signals or to
listen in on their Communications you
know they're right next to China Japan
is also positioning more troops here so
this is the first part of our chain and
when paired with training that Japan and
U.S troops are doing to simulate Island
and amphibious Warfare it sends a really
strong signal to China that Japan is
ready to respond if needed this line
also serves as like a physical barrier
that any Chinese ship or submarine would
have to pass through in order to access
the Pacific Ocean it's a line that Japan
can easily control and monitor and it
also builds a wall of missiles any
calculus that China is making on whether
or not to invade Taiwan or to do
anything in the region we'll have to now
factor in this wall of missiles ready to
roll overall this increased military
presence on this chain of islands gives
Japan and by extension the United States
the ability to monitor Communications
and troop movements of China preparing
them to act quickly it also gives them
the ability to pre-position troops and
supplies throughout the region which is
a major logistical Advantage but all of
this comes with a massive price tag so
Japan which is formerly a pacifist
Nation without like a huge military is
actually planning to double their
defense spending they're spending way
more on buying weapons than they ever
have before and 97 of those weapons are
coming from the United
[Music]
the island change strategy continues
down here with the Philippines close to
Taiwan and close to the South China Sea
the U.S knows that it needs to bolster
its presence here but it's not as
straightforward as it is in Japan
the Philippines was a U.S Colony for
decades it's a very sensitive history
and even after Filipino Independence the
U.S maintained a military presence in
the Philippines until like the 90s and
then they eventually kicked out the U.S
as many saw it as just an enduring
Legacy of U.S colonialism but a more
aggressive China has become a major
threat to the Philippines now listen I'm
not going to go into like a full South
China Sea thing here but just know that
China claims all of this as their
Maritime boundary it's literally a line
with nine dashes that some Chinese
official in 1948 Drew by hand on a map
this line blasts through the boundaries
that the rest of the world recognizes as
the Filipino territorial Waters so
there's a conflict in the ocean and now
on a daily basis Filipino fishing
vessels are harassed by Chinese military
vessels who threaten them if they don't
leave their Waters in 2022 China put a
temporary stop to All fishing in the
South China Sea denying the Philippines
of ability to fish in the west
Philippine Sea which is rightfully their
Waters but it's crazier than that the
Chinese Navy is like full-blown just
bullying the Philippines they like show
up with lasers to harass and blind
Filipino ships I mean let's remember the
Philippines is a much smaller Nation
than China and doesn't really have a
Navy even close to what China has so now
they're in this impossible decision they
have to choose between giving up their
sovereignty and fishing rights to their
aggressive neighbor China or partnering
with their former colonizer who also
wants to repel China and in this case
they chose the latter China has pushed
too hard it's pushed the Philippines in
the South China Sea what they call the
West Philippine Sea well the Philippines
is planning to boost this military
presence in the dispute at South China
Sea it started in 2014 when they allowed
the U.S back in for the first time in 22
years the U.S presence will technically
be in bases that are owned by the
Philippines but the US can have troops
build barracks and other military
installations and can have
pre-positioned supplies there as well
it's basically like the US has bases
there but it's like it's actually the
Philippines and as part of all of this
that we've been talking about in late
2022 they expanded their agreement
giving the U.S military access to four
more bases bringing the total number of
bases on the Philippines up to nine and
look where they selected to put them
here in the north of the country
strategically close to Taiwan and
helping fill their Gap in their island
chain that they're creating this now
allows us to have a military presence
really close to Taiwan the U.S trains
very closely with their Filipino
counterparts making them ready to
respond very quickly to an invasion in
Taiwan while also repelling Chinese
bullying of Filipino fishing activity
okay so now that island chain is filling
out giving the U.S and its Regional
Partners a solid blockade to the Pacific
and it continues all the way down around
the South China Sea because of the U.S
presence in Singapore this is a very
united front but it doesn't stop here
the last part of the strategy is
potentially the most significant and it
has to do with Australia a country that
is also alarmed by China's rise in the
region so there's this military pact
between the U.S the UK and Australia
it's called August what it means is that
these three countries will work together
to create a unified submarine force that
will Patrol the Pacific first what it
means is that the U.S is giving giving
nuclear submarine technology its most
powerful and advanced weapon freely to
Australia here here are the designs to
our most powerful weapons take them
foreign country
and then the US and UK will base
submarines out of this port here in
Australia it's called Perth Australian
Sailors will ride alongside U.S and UK
sailors during submarine deployments
they will learn together they will work
together they will share classified
intelligence what this means is that
there will be a significantly larger
number of submarines patrolling these
Waters and remember these are
nuclear-powered submarines which we made
a whole video on as well these things
can be underwater for months they can go
on these long patrols over to Taiwan and
the South China Sea they can close up
these key choke points plugging holes in
their growing line against China and
crucially we can be pretty damn certain
that a lot of these submarines will be
carrying nuclear weapons adding yet
another layer of deterring power to an
already really powerful line of defense
and if this wasn't enough Australia is
also building a permanent Hangar for U.S
B-52 bombers up here in the Tyndall Air
Base in Northern Australia these U.S
bombers carry Conventional Weapons but
they also carry nukes so now U.S bombers
carrying nuclear weapons will have a
permanent home in Australia there's
going to be a lot more military hardware
in the Pacific because of this Hardware
that carries the most powerful and
dangerous weapons we have this is a very
aggressive signal to China that the West
is ready
so now if you look at the whole thing
this whole chain you see how robust this
presence is this is what that military
official meant by transformative the
military name for this is the first
island chain and it is at the heart of
the US and its allies strategy to
counter and contain China and it's easy
to see that this island chain while
protecting a lot of different interests
for a lot of different countries really
centers on Taiwan a major purpose for
all of this militarization the missiles
the subs the air bases the troops is to
prepare for conflict in Taiwan and this
is where we get to the Paradox of
deterrence you prepare to fight so that
you don't have to fight all of this
preparation might be just what is needed
for China to decide that it would be too
costly to invade Taiwan but the other
side of that Paradox is that all of this
looks an awful lot like overt escalation
in a conflict if you're China this chain
of islands is clearly your enemy trying
to box you in to monitor your every move
a superpower from the other side of the
world flooding your region with more
military hardware to stop your influence
it would be impossible for this plan to
not contribute to a rising of tensions
between the two superpowers all this as
the U.S prepares for a potential
conflict with China how close are we to
all-out conflict between the world's two
largest superpowers
foreign
Chinese president Xi Jinping has already
called this a policy of encirclement and
suppression and let's be honest he's
right whether you like it or not this is
containment old school Cold War style
containment it's hard not to see it when
you look at this map and the Chinese
foreign minister said that it would
literally be impossible for China to not
fight back to take a move that
retaliates against this move which means
that if the US and its allies aren't
careful with all of this
it may send a signal to China that now
is the time to invade Taiwan before all
of this plan can fully be implemented in
that sense this strategy could provoke
the very conflict that it is trying to
deter
foreign
thanks for watching today's video thanks
again to co-pilot for sponsoring the
video link in my description if you want
to get started 14 days for free
um I wanted to tell you about a couple
things number one this is a poster and
it's it's why all maps are wrong and
it's a beautiful poster on really nice
thick paper with dozens and dozens of
map projections if you're a map nerd
like me this kind of stuff is really fun
we have Luts and presets that we use to
color our videos and photos that we
developed with a professional colorist
and if you are interested in joining our
community on patreon it is called The
Newsroom we publish an extra video there
every month where we show you behind the
scenes of how we do what we do here in
the studio
we're gonna have Johnny sit there this
is Kyle oh my God even though you didn't
print out any Maps
um I also published my scripts there and
a lot of stuff but it's really just a
way for you to support what we're trying
to do here at independent journalism on
YouTube thank you for being here thank
you for watching let me know your
thoughts on this video and uh I look
forward to a lively debate in the
comments have a good day
foreign